we go now to the latest in the final in
the fight against the coronavirus
the seven-day u.s average is below 30
000 new cases a day
for the first time in nearly a year that
number is still high but it's a sign
that vaccines are working
jamie dukes joins us with potentially
more good news jamie good morning
there's a vaccination study involving
kids as young as six months old
what can you tell us about it yeah just
little babies enrique good morning 144
kids 11 and younger
are now participating in pfizer's
clinical trial
it will eventually enroll more than 4
500 children
with the goal of applying for emergency
use authorization for kids vaccines by
the fall
the family we spoke to says it was eager
for the opportunity and is encouraging
others to sign up for parents ottavio
and zaneta good
the first step to getting back out into
the world was getting their family
vaccinated
their sons three-year-old andal and
eight-month-old soren were among the
first kids
under the age of five to receive the
pfizer vaccine
zaneda who has a phd in immunology felt
confident about signing her kids up for
the phase one clinical trial at stanford
what made you guys decide no we want to
go ahead and do this
vaccines are one of the greatest
inventions of immunology
and it's like the key for us to feel
good and safe about
our kids one thing that we're concerned
with is the long-term effects of covid
and it's like yeah we'll take the
vaccine any day over the potential
downsides of covid dr yvonne maldonado
is overseeing the trial which will help
researchers determine dosing
the goal is for kids to have a strong
immune response with minimal side
effects
children have a tendency to develop
fevers
more often than adults do in general and
we also know that children
frequently respond to lower doses with
good immune responses
zaneta says andal and soren were given
one tenth of an adult dose
and baby soarin returned last week to
have his blood drawn
did your kids have any side effects not
anything major
under after his first dose he was a
little bit low on energy for one day and
had a sore
arm one day but after second those both
kids had nothing
maldonado says kids side effects will
likely be similar to adults
but it's a small price to pay covid is
the 10th
most common cause of death in children
in the u.s right now
it is causing children to be sick with a
disease for which we don't know
the long-term effects for the good
family
shots also mean they're more comfortable
at some of their favorite places
like the park what i really miss is
going to the playground and meeting
new families and making friends and
coming back to our house and playing you
know and
now we are happy to open up to the world
again now we feel
we feel protected and we don't feel
worried anymore and it's a wonderful
feeling
researchers will use blood work to
determine how strong the vaccine
response is at fending off the virus
if the children don't generate enough
antibodies they can return for a higher
dosage
jamie the cdc is flagging a new concern
about vaccines and a rare heart
condition in kids
what do we know about that yeah we're
just learning about this the cdc says
it's investigating a small number of
teens
and young adults who developed the rare
heart condition called myocarditis after
being vaccinated
while the cdc did not specify how many
people developed it
the agency says all appear to have mild
symptoms
and there is no clear link between the
vaccine
and the condition and the cdc guidance
has not changed
it is encouraging everyone 12 and older
to get vaccinated enrique
jamie thank you